[Music]
so that feel good time our series of
more perfect union aids to show that
what unites us is far greater than what
divides us this morning we're sharing a
story of an extraordinary reunion
imagine being so desperate for your
child's safety that you put her in the
hands of a complete stranger and then
you rely on him to do the right thing
that's the situation one mom faced 15
years ago as she tried to get her
daughter out of a war ravaged nation and
to the US for medical care CBS this
morning Saturday co-anchor Dana Jacobson
shows us how the mother picked just the
right guy to help and how only now
they're getting a chance to say thank
you 20 year old Maya Hughes and her
mother's I Nev C say who simply goes by
Z call California home but 15 years ago
the two are on an extended African stay
in Z's native Sierra Leone yeah I wanted
her to learn every bit of my background
kind of get back to my roots and visit
my grandmother Maya picked up one
speaking Creole within two weeks of what
we got there and completely forgot how
to speak English it was a fun adventure
but Sierra Leone had just emerged from a
devastating Civil War and was not an
easy place for a mother and small child
I hadn't thought of that
so thoroughly to know that the country
is still not in the shape that it should
be one night a fire broke out in Mayas
room burning the mattress she was
sleeping on Z raced to rescue her I was
wearing I remember smooth I remember
much after that she couldn't stay here
anymore and I gathered every penny I
owned at that moment went to the airport
only had enough money to go buy a ticket
just for her and that is where the story
of Tom Perry on occasion we can build
things tom Perriello is a former US
congressman but at the time he was a
young lawyer in Sierra Leone working on
a war crimes court he was at the airport
to fly home for his grandmother's
funeral I got to the front of the line
and the airline attendant said your tom
Perriello right and which I got from
time to time and I said sure so we get
to the airport to add
the counter clerk to see who was
traveling to the United States she goes
in creole now it's mine meaning that
white man or woman it's traveling I
approached him I said excuse me sir
I said could you please travel with my
daughter it's an emergency and of course
my response was no and may I repeat heck
no and so I pleaded with him and he
finally said okay I'll do it the two
strangers boarded a plane to head home
but first they had to make a stop in
Cote d'Ivoire then a second stop in
Brussels Belgium before heading to the
States in all about 7,500 miles and 20
hours of travel I was just crying a long
and complicated journey that frankly had
plenty of drama and complications along
the way it was then to me on the plane I
remember that he was singing in Creole
wasn't even just that I knew one song it
was just basically one verse over and
over again for about an hour when they
landed at Dulles Airport in Virginia
Perry Ella got the little girl safely to
her grandmother but it was too late to
make his connecting flight he missed his
own grandmother's funeral she would join
Maya about a month after she sent her
daughter to the u.s. for 15 years
they never saw or spoke to Perry yellow
they never had the chance to thank him
until now we arranged for a face-to-face
reunion in New York City after the trio
reconnected by email thanks to one of
Z's cousin's 15 years looking for ghosts
a person that didn't exist is this
closure in a way for all of yours at the
start of something else
I guess it started something else I want
to call a close your but it feels like a
new beginning because I rethought it
how do you thank someone for what he did
for you you can't you can't
honestly I can never thank him enough no
matter what I do from this point forward
it will never be
for what he did you have lots of reasons
to say no to something and and there are
moments to say yes and I'm really glad
that I did in that case as crazy as it
was I don't wanna cry but I'm really
emotional body because that's like he
saved my life because if I would have
stayed it's I don't know where I would
have been I think it was destiny because
it could have been anybody and anything
could have happened and he brought me
back here so I don't think I can say
thank you really
oh what a decision for a mom to put hurt
with that stranger
Dana says they tried to reunite before
but they were a series of missed
connections it just never happened which
is why it took so long but I bet his
grandmother would have been proud of him
yes all right we'll be right back